Amazon I've got video from you want to
talk to you guys before
um stuff so right I can't provide them
with that yeah
um like I said and uh
like I said just making sure you guys
are okay there you care if I check on
the boys real quick just make sure
everything good and then you think
Stephen would mind the fires if I stop
and talk to him
uh no I don't think he would find I just
we're just trying to close out your
missing person report right yeah um
because your daughter up there
um keeps on calling them okay
and apparently they got the media
involved also so before it becomes
national news we're trying to
let everybody know hey we found them
they're okay yeah they're
you know wow all right
all right you guys all good boys yeah
because home school still how's that
going
you learn learning all right so all
right Monica that's all I need okay um I
will
uh reach out to your husband
and talk to him I gotta go up that way
anyways what's the place he's working at
uh
okay yeah I'm just I'm you guys aren't
in any trouble yeah at all yeah I'm just
trying to help them close out a missing
person yeah
yeah that's fine we just decided uh
that I can leave yeah we're just ready
to do something new and there's nothing
wrong with that
um there's nothing wrong with that so
um like I said she finally really would
love I guess he said he's got a good
report with their husband yeah um he
would love to talk to him so I'll I'll
talk to him and he can decide then if he
wants to talk to him or not like I said
all right if you don't want to talk to
him it's fine I'll let your husband do
all the talking okay that sounds fine
all right perfect you guys have a
wonderful day okay
how are you good I'm looking for one of
your employees
Mr Stephen Lutz Steven Lutz yeah he
should be out there at the tire Bay okay
around the building the third perfect
he's not any trouble
foreign
hey you know Mr Chief Riley yeah I do
um you want to give him a call not
really come on let's go over to my truck
you're not you're not any trouble okay
okay can I put my food in my truck yeah
go no go ahead go ahead yeah
um we're just uh
look out don't wear you you lived in
Illinois right um so what we got going
on
you and your family have been reported
as missing people yeah I know my
daughter's trying to cause a bunch of
trouble before so okay
so you know you're aware of all that
okay oh yeah so now they are sparking up
history out there
so we're trying to just close up
yeah I just got done talking to your
wife yeah and young boys we just got
away from all the mess yeah and if you
guys want to go and
yes so he he really wants to talk to you
okay okay
um he gave me his phone number okay
that's up to you okay you can call him
on my cell phone okay however you yeah
I can just call him online I guess if I
if I want to I don't know if I want to
but
um it don't have to be anything longer
thing yeah he just wants to hear your
guys's voices your wife didn't want to
talk to him yeah I offered that option
to her too and she said no but I did
tell her like I'm telling you you guys
are on my body camera yes sir I don't
know that um so and I I can provide this
to them show them that you guys are
alive and well okay
yeah like you would really love to talk
to you he says you're not in any trouble
whatsoever okay
um because your daughter apparently he's
got the media involved now the media
yeah oh boy so that's why I don't know
how they found us I really don't I mean
I remember I was out here Caputo doing a
welfare check yeah yeah that's why oh
that's how you come across it yeah
that's how I come across it okay okay
um they were just outlooking poking
around and yeah one of the guys in
Benson from Ben's PD got a call asking
and one of our deputies happened to know
that I had dealt with you guys before
yeah it's like hey can you guys go check
it's just a welfare check yeah you know
we just want to can I just like I said
I've been talking on the phone with them
this morning yeah and he that's fine I I
talked to him if you want to call him up
I can talk to her okay I don't have no
okay I like Riley's all right yeah he
said he had no problems with you he just
no
what's your name Danny Romero Romero
okay and you guys are geared up huh yeah
everybody has their own preference um
it's just easier for me to throw on the
vest and carry on my Capital invest in
that yeah yeah
I mean
make sure you're right and left-handed
both
no okay yeah no I just see well actually
I didn't know if you were ambidextrous
or I can shoot with both yes
um I'm predominantly
semper fry I don't know it's the Marines
yeah
the sun was in the Marines oh nice yeah
hi yes I was looking for a trip Valley
this is Debbie Romero coaches County
yeah
how you doing I'm uh standing right here
with Mr uh Lutz he didn't want to get a
phone call but he's going to talk to you
off of my cell phone so we're on speaker
yeah yes that would be great Steven
we've been looking for it man yeah
yeah we were concerned uh Brittany was
worried you know there was something
wrong and she hasn't heard from me in a
while yeah yeah
so uh nothing wrong just getting away
from it
tired of all the crap so
okay I mean yeah
I'm sorry sorry I scared you but uh yeah
I just uh
just I did there's a lot of things that
I don't need my life around there yeah I
got you yeah yeah
um so you're doing all right I'm doing
great never bad
he's doing good Monica doing good yep
yeah they're all good yep okay so hey so
Brittany and even you know Mary they're
pretty worried oh they should be yeah
can't treat people like you can't treat
people like that and expect them to stay
around
yeah yep no I don't know I don't
I don't it's up to you what you want to
tell him are you like planning on just
living there or do you have any
intentions on coming back I'm not coming
back
okay there ain't nothing there for me
I got you yeah all right what about
them I'm gonna try and sell it
you wanna buy it
I'll make you hell of a deal
ten thousand cash
you want to I mean I think Brittany it
would be nice if Brittany and Mary knew
at least what was going on so that way
they're not worried and they can at
least know you know from Europe yeah
after they stabbed me in the back
for it after they stabbed me in the back
it's up to you I don't even know nothing
about I don't want to know nothing about
where I'm at or who I am or nothing
okay
I'm sorry I I'm sorry I freaked you out
but uh
I have to at least release that we've
made located you know we've located you
yeah just don't tell them where I'm at
please
don't you know I'm alive I'm well
everything's great everything's good
this officer here it can attest to it
all
and nobody else needs to know where I'm
at
it ain't none of Nobody's Business
so you can verify something that's why I
suggestions
you walked away he's
yeah okay yeah so um
if you need for communication for your
media stuff
um they can contact our Sheriff's Office
and I can we can uh um I want this close
where they're at but I can verify that
um my media social media people that
deal with that they can verify that
they've been spoken to and they're alive
like I said and all of this is on my
body camera
yeah I definitely appreciate it um and
I'll go ahead and let let you know I
won't tell her the location but I'll let
her know that we located it and now I
can refer to you guys if you want yeah
um there you're gonna
okay
all right sounds good hey thanks again
yeah then uh I don't know if uh I don't
know if you guys want to
go about getting reports uh
yeah I'll text you that would email it
or I can yeah I can send you the report
number and then once it's been approved
um give me a couple of days
for me to writing stuff you can contact
our Sheriff's Office our main dispatch
number actually
um I'll text you the phone number too
for our uh
admin office
and you can request a report and they
can and they can send it to you
yeah and then they'll they'll send you
all reports uh what's it called uh if
you want to request everything involving
them
um yeah that they can send you all that
stuff
okay
contact with them not telling
specifically where but so that way I can
kind of follow his wishes and yeah go
from there to say that we found them and
they wish to
um remain
unlocated in a sense just that we just
want to know that they're alive and
they're alive so
okay excellent hey thank you so much for
the help and this is going to save us a
lot of headaches so all right
all right hey thanks you're welcome you
have a good day yeah you too
hey before I go okay yeah I just if I
could just get your information just so
I could put that from my room before I
know that I uh got made contact with you
I don't know what else he had to say I'm
sorry I walked off I just no he doesn't
have to tell anybody where I'm at yeah
um with that being said also he he can
request the reports right yeah um and
stuff and if you want to find out he can
do his own digging yeah I appreciate it
I just let him know that I never give
you any trouble I don't give it's uh I'm
not like I don't know hey I'm in a
little town
yeah yeah so I've seen this at night
foreign
yes uh-huh what's your date of birth
and you guys of course
I'm gonna be in there for a while uh I
don't know that's maybe get an apartment
something we're going to do something
more steady well um our plan was to to
navigate the United States and end up
back in Illinois okay and so that my
kids could make it along before road
trip right before my before my kids are
18 yeah they're not far from it eight
years and I said and before this world
gets any crazier than what it is I just
wanted to take them and show them like
the Grand Canyon and okay and Hollywood
and just show them the world you know
because I'm a truck driver I've seen
that I've seen a lot of the world but
it's on the interstates you know yeah so
if I pulled my retirement and we just
packed up and and left okay and found us
a little RV down here and yeah yeah
and uh I liked it at first but I don't
really like it now so we're trying to
find us a little bigger one a little
bigger one but um right now we're like
six hours from
uh just a few hours from
good I mean and then all the Indian
artifacts and stuff that's around here
yeah I said this would be a good place
to land I could start working and then
we can go out on like weekend trips and
see and see a lot more than if we were
just trying to travel you know so
that's what I'm doing it's kind of a
work work vacation yeah work in progress
yeah working vacation you know because I
can do anything you have a good phone
number I can get a hold of you if I need
to yes
okay and that's out of Mississippi
yeah I I literally dropped all of all my
cell phones and just left we just left
start all over well I I got into some
things I shouldn't have back home and
um I need to get away from that
would you like to have the chief's
number
I've got his number uh Riley yeah yeah
I've got his number yeah can you say if
you want it you can have it okay yeah
well you can write it down for me just
in case it's changed but
yeah he's he's a good guy I I don't know
what he's up to right now I think he's
but the media being involved he's being
pushed from your family side of the
media and everybody else you know yeah
he's trying um
he's a chief he's trying to figure
things out he's a good guy
not that you know I don't know you guys
out here but he is a good guy
oh I like Riley I just we're decent guys
too
I have no reason to not get into that
too high about to take your ear out huh
yeah I'm just
I'm in love with your weather
really well well you come from a place
where it's freezing all the time oh yeah
but I got my tomato I got tomatoes on my
tomato did you see that at the trailer I
got some tomatoes on there yeah so
there you go okay thank you very much um
if I were to pick a place I guess it'd
be someone with warm weather because I
got family in Wyoming and I've been
there during the winter times and I've
been to places I lived in Wyoming is it
the same Zone same is here oh it's from
it here just cold oh it's like I mean
atmosphere yeah you know it's not bad
there see I want to go up there I want
to go up to Wyoming and suck it out you
know what I wouldn't mind living there
maybe as a retirement place I like the
ranches you know I like to stick to the
ranches if I can't um
thank you
if I don't have to be outside during the
winter time that's why I go over here
during retirement yeah I don't want to
be a cop up there and be up in the
winter time yeah yeah yeah I just got I
got tired of the winter and uh winter
the Winter's harsh on my body we went to
we went to Pennsylvania and that's where
we got our dog yeah most beautiful dog
yeah yeah she's gonna be a real kind of
dog issue Cane Corso Cane Corso this is
real smart is there any laws on that
around here no no as long as you don't
teach them to attack people no I'm not
gonna node the opposite they're
um
I watched a lot of social media and
stuff and I do a lot of canine stuff
flipping dogs up and stuff and Cane
Corso is one of a couple one of the
family dogs yeah yeah security dogs and
stuff for security yeah for security and
just family just great family dogs I
like it yeah once they're attached to a
family they're they're very loyal dogs
right with that family yeah yeah yeah
yeah and I like it down here because you
can take them into the stores yeah you
can't do that up in Illinois you take a
dog into Walmart you get thrown you got
the cops out there yeah but around here
they're pretty lenient yeah we might get
some places you know if it's not a
service the thing is that the service
the whole service dog right but
um around here they're pretty lenient as
long as you've done a leash and he's not
pissing and crapping and biting people
no people don't don't do nothing and
then she can get oriented to people and
that way it should be less likely I hope
to yeah because if she if something
happens she gets aggressive then she's
gonna have to come up
I'll let you go back to work okay thank
you pleasure meeting you yeah if I need
anything else I'm always here and
otherwise
it's a lot of drama there's a lot of old
people there and my kids are playing and
they're they don't like that so you know
so I'm gonna go up to check the turkey
place if we might go stay at the gym
okay because they got a lot of kids in
there
yes
apartment or something apartment yeah
yeah yeah so yeah yeah because uh I mean
I'm not against the apartment I just if
we want to right now we can just hitch
up and go I'm trying to find land do you
know any land for sale I'm not around
here I know that I'd love to build a
house
yeah I'll check it out all right you can
uh if you're on your phone you can just
Google uh
yourself I'll do that thank you all
right appreciate it all right sir you
have a good one